generational Warfare has to stop let's
start with that enough of Boomers versus
X versus Z versus Millennials but this
headline also has another interesting
tact which is like the pendulum swings
the Seesaw of generations you react more
to the one above you or below you and I
know a lot of talk about gen Z
constantly but gen Alpha is coming and
they're a totally different group this
is how it works out and again they're
affected by what they see above them and
what's coming in technology beneath them
and so for marketers for business people
for parents for all of us understanding
what makes a generation tick is great we
generalize too much and there's tons of
people in each generation that don't act
like The Stereotype but what I'm really
excited about for this audience that
watches my content is really
understanding Trends and setting up your
business your family the things you care
about for the next 5 10 and 15 years and
gen Z knows gen Alpha is
coming